a lot of action this morning pat on our
reddit discussion forum which you can
join at david pakman.com slash read it a
few of the conversations happening in
the last 24 hours let's start with the
first one an article posted about how
there is a Harvard Law Professor
claiming that Donald Trump's Obama
wiretapping claims could get him
impeached a very interesting article a
speculative article nonetheless and you
can see TV PS Pat which is the reddit
account of producer Pat Forde
participating in the conversation saying
something very profound as you can see
absolutely well i will let people see it
for themselves i'm not going to give
everything away here okay also there was
a post that was created about so-called
genital mutilation and I say so-called
only because the article refers not only
to female genital mutilation but it also
attempts to wrap in male circumcision as
genital mutilation this is an assertion
that some people on the reddit agree
with and many people on our reddit
disagree with I encourage you to go to
david pakman.com slash reddit and
participate in that discussion because
it is quite interesting also from our
reddit discussion forum a pretty
legitimate question why have insurance
on health care at all and this is a
conversation that is very astutely
pointing out that you know most
countries don't have the system that we
have if they're at our level of
development and maybe this entire
conversation is about the specifics of
ACA versus aaha is misguided in some way
a point that i made earlier today on the
show a very good point right it's just
unfortunately given the political
context that were in it's just not even
a discussion that's necessary at this
point not as are not realistic yeah not
realistic at all also from our reddit
discussion forum an article found out
there's an article written about it was
discovered that some chinese media
misunderstood a satirical trump story
for real news and it relates to Donald
Trump jokingly not not jokingly it's a
fake story right that Donald Trump
ordered his aides to wrap tin foil
around the White
house telephone it was a goof right but
some Chinese media did not understand
the satirical aspect of it and actually
reported that if something that Donald
Trump is actually doing and also from
our reddit discussion forum I think that
you're going to like this I've been
doing these YouTube live streams and it
would be great if you participated in
them I do them I don't know two three
times a week sort of on a random
schedule at the beginning of the live
stream when you're about to go live the
app tells you that it's going to take a
thumbnail and that'll be the thumbnail
for the event and usually I make some
kind of funny face not a man I didn't
got to make it exciting absolutely and
someone created sort of a compilation of
the faces that have comprised the
YouTube thumbnails and we'll show you
some of these one referring to shocked
David another YouTube thumbnail overly
attached David referencing a popular
internet meme another thumbnail murder
David apparently uh not not seeing that
as a friendly expression another one not
bad David doing what some people
consider the universal not bad meme face
and I think we have one or two more
nameless look because I can't David
that's the last one Ben Dixon host of
the Benjamin Dixon show he was on one of
the live streams as a just was an
audience member and after it ended he
sent me a text and he said you should
see how YouTube seems to always capture
the weirdest moment for the thumbnail
and I said no no no I'm posing for those
it's not by accident that every single
thumbnail on a YouTube live stream is me
making an insane face do you remember
those emotion charts from grade school
yeah at some point make one of you for
each single emotion happy sad the whole
gamut yeah a couple more live streams
and we'll definitely have that check out
the live streams they're all archived on
our YouTube channel also youtube.com
slash the david pakman show but really
what i would love for you to do is get
us over the 3000 we have almost 3000
subscribers on our reddit discussion
forum and you can get us there if you go
to david pakman.com slash read it and
hit that blue subscribe button